since tomorrow joe biden will be
president of the united states we're
sort of closing the book on the trump
presidency today in a few different ways
and one such way is looking at approval
rating donald trump is leaving the white
house
with the lowest job approval of his
presidency which is 29
and yet it still seems so high
how could nearly a third of the people
in this country less than a third but
nearly a third of the people in this
country
think he's doing a good job still he's
been doing
nothing for months other than inciting
that riotous insurrection on january 6th
and it is true that trump voters
have grown more critical of trump
in his post-election conduct the share
of trump supporters
who describe his conduct as poor has
doubled over the last two months from 10
percent to 20 percent
a significant majority of americans
don't want
trump trump to remain a major political
figure after he leaves office about
two-thirds say
trump should be uh uh should evaporate
as a as a primary political figure of
the united states
joe biden is entering with 64
positive opinion which is great only in
the sense that it bodes well
and sets biden up well for the crucial
start of his presidency where we need
everybody on the same page in order to
finally get this pandemic under control
scale up vaccination and do the things
that have to be done
so those are all good signs but in term
of the in terms of the january 6th
trump riots three-quarters of the public
say that trump bears at least some
responsibility
for the violence and destruction
committed by some of his supporters
52 percent say trump bears a lot of
responsibility but we still have 24
percent
nearly a quarter of this country says
trump has zero responsibility for what
took place
that's extraordinarily weaponized
disinformation
and then maybe most disturbing
a majority of republicans still think
that donald trump
actually won the election understand
that
64 percent of republican voters
still believe as of a few days ago when
this survey was done
that it is actually donald trump who won
the election
two-thirds of republicans believe the
guy who's being sworn in tomorrow
did not really win and by the way
six percent of democrats also believe
trump won
i'd be interested in talking to some of
those folks that that's that's quite a
bit uh
that's just as depressing quite frankly
meanwhile
this is not the only data point from pew
in the gallop
presidential approval tracking poll
trump also falling there to a presidency
low of 34
approval and i i have the same reaction
to both the 29
and 34 approval numbers 29 and 34
approval for trump are way too high
those numbers tell us that something is
very wrong with the country as if we
didn't already know but it confirms it
approval should be zero if only
all of this had been completely
predictable when donald trump
ran for president back in 2015. oh wait
a second
it was completely predictable and we
were predicting that it would be this
bad
so there will be time for postmortems
but it's still shocking and saddening
that there are people who thought
hillary would be the same as trump or
hillary would be as bad as trump or it
would make no difference to the to the
day
day-to-day lives of americans whether
it's trump or hillary
some people over the last year were
saying similar things about joe biden
joe biden would be
as bad as trump i hope no one is
listening to those people anymore
because they've given up their right to
be listened to
i'm not saying they shouldn't be allowed
to speak i'm not violating anyone
suggesting anyone's first amendment
rights be violated i'm just saying
at this point we have enough evidence to
realize
we shouldn't be listening to those
people by the way
there are also people who went from
voting for bernie
to voting for trump that also knowing
everything we know now
is extraordinarily disturbing it was
disturbing back in 2016
it's even more disturbing now because
everything has been so utterly
predictable
and yet some people are still acting
surprised so
good news trump's going out with the
lowest approval rating of his presidency
bad news nearly a third of the country
nearly a third of the country meaning
about 70 million people
still support the
uh um uh uh absolutely
i'm sorry no 90 something million people
my mouth was wrong
near something around 90 million people
still think trump is doing a good job
and that's going to be something we'll
have to deal with
for much much more time than trump is in
office which is fortunately
just a few more hours one of our
sponsors is a free
mobile game called word forest which
i've been having
a great time playing on my phone there
are not a lot of mobile games that
i actually am into but word forest is
one i actually
enjoy because i feel like it's helping
me keep my mind sharp we need that right
now it's a word game where you connect
letters in any direction to form
hidden word matches with over 2
000 levels you will never get bored of
playing it was really simple to learn
how to play
because it starts out easy but i've been
loving how it gets more difficult as i
progress but i find that
the whole experience is just relaxing it
doesn't have to be super fast paced
it's awesome for anyone who loves word
games and has a good vocabulary or
wants to improve it go ahead and put
yourself to the test
it's free just go to the apple or google
store
and search for word forest